Identification. This is tape two side two which will begin in approximately ten seconds time.
One of the things of course that concerned. The family was there was no longer the income from but now.
And none of my brothers wanted to be involved in that kind of thing. So we then began to wonder what we'd live on.
Well at that time there was a thing that was called state aid which the local said Mother should apply for.
And that gave her a pension of a car in and so much for each child under fourteen. And. It was sufficient.
She made all our clothes. And then my sisters began to sew.
So need to make it but not adequately associative but they were made.
I mean there were times when the sole of my shoe coming off and I had want to stay because it would drag along.
And she'd get the last hammer
and put a tech in it to hold it back so I could go off to school things like that were happening.
But she wanted to work so she went to. One of the local hotels.
And there were these two hotels one in the south of Tampa Holcomb the other in the north.
And the one in the north was the one which we knew best because they had boys who were around about the same age as my
brothers and I went to school together. And their names were Perkins.
And there was a great attraction here for for my brother. Walter because they had a stable of horses.
But mother went along and she saw the daughter of the publican because the daughter managed this.
Power Of course made of timber upstairs and downstairs. And I had a big barn of her and typical country.
It was just lovely to see a building that had a second floor. Only the pumps have the second floor.
So mother went to we the daughter of the publican. And we need said Would you like some work and mother said yes.
So he went to the pub twice a week. And she did the laundry for Winnie and father.
I think there were a couple of brothers and she did the awning. And she absolutely loved it. We need more of my mother.
And I always ended the day by going into the ladies' power. And and having a drink. Just so lovely.
Then she'd always give Mother things to bring bottles of lemonade a couple of bottles of lemonade or ginger beer
or something like that for the kids and mother would come home about. My very thickly law where. Bush scrapped.
And it also had a local to Belgium symmetry. Which by their had clothes. It was quite a.
But the cemetery always festa dated as we often visited the cemetery and was also.
When did you know and there is usually most of you know it was nice we often went to. GRACE.
I think that symmetries do tell me his story. Anyhow.
I'm fascinated by cemeteries even to this day but I'll never forget that symmetry
and the tombstones were just so beautiful and I suppose they were all in erected
and those people who were very there in the last century in the nineteenth century. Anyhow.
Mother would come home quite tired but placement late. And there was a dinner all cooked ready for her.
You see John would be forking during the day but he also for the farmers
but he always got home in time to prepare the meal. Can I just ask.
The boys went and got jobs another that it had not happened and what was their sadness that your fun wasn't continuing.
The boys didn't want to continue with father's farm because they just didn't want to work.
They wanted to work with was bigger money.
So they cut came during the cane season four of them in fact was very young people
and John was sort of managing a dairy. He went off very early in the morning and he'd come home.
About half past four in the afternoon always making sure he was in time to cook the meal. So.
And it was like this with my other brothers. You know we had each other we had each other.
That was important that that vacuum that had been created.
Was indeed quite deep quite deep and he was a very strict person my father
and I think to some extent the bowl use We're rather pleased to enjoy the new found freedom wouldn't dispute that at
all but when he went to certain. Left it left an emptiness.
Well mother would come home and all she would have to do sit have a dinner. And.
She'd cry sometimes you just cry that she'd lost my father and when mother would sit there and cry.
It would just rip my heart into and after she'd cry. She'd sing. And we got used to this over the years.
She cried for my father for years and years
and years after his death so that was going back to the old house that involve him.
Mother was beginning to feel lonely. Lot as many people kind of that father had car.
And although she had the neighbors. She liked the company and ship also with the island women.
And one day she came home from work. She got more work. Apart from the hotel. She got to work in other places as well.
So I know how she mounted been earning about a pound a week or so which was very big money. I thought she had.
Sovereign. Anyhow. She came home one day and she said we're going to leave this house now.
And we all gathered around her and asked her where we were going and what.
Well that day she'd actually been up to Mobile and. For some reason or other.
And made inquiries about a certain house which she knew was becoming vacant and it was then vacant.
And it was possible for us to move into this house which was about a ten minute walk away from where I lived.
And from also it was next door to where. As a daughter of hers who force a step daughter lived.
With her husband children whom we didn't really know. They were just completely separate.
With these the daughters of early marriage. Yes yes.
So it was being close it was having relations who were close that she needed. So she said. So next week.
You have to pack up helping to pack up. So we all got stuck into packing up.
And the neighbors for whom work for said you don't have to get a carrier.
Mrs massing out take all your things and he had huge way.
So he loaded up the way put his good horses into it
and off with all our belongings up to the other house which we always call the new.
And it was nice because it was on a very high start.
And we could play downstate as it was like having a huge cubby house in a way down. Yes and it had mo bedroom.
Yeah it was different but it didn't have the so that the old house the balcony.
Did you feel that as a little girl you know why I missed.
I missed the outside opened fire kitchen which was my father's
and there was no way to sit around tell stories as it were you know and the floors were polished.
And the verandah was scrubbed and all that kind of thing. So but.
None of the boys came with us because by then they'd gone off and I was living with different farmers
but mother knew all those families and they knew she was quite happy about the boys.
And some of the families continue to send the boys to school like that. And help with the milking or whatever it was.
When the boys left home
and you were in the new house did that change things to do to girls then take on different roles.
Did they do more if they had duties. When we moved house of course it meant losing and although he came and went.
It wasn't. So. But I have to tell you this first. That father died and the year was nineteen twenty four.
And at nineteen twenty six. My auntie Kate. So when we moved to move.
Shortly after that she died which was a terrible blow a dreadful blow because we'd lost really.
All the support that the boys would give that night. To us and we'd moved up there to be mainly near Kate and Kate and.
So all of this was quite dramatic a matter of fact for not only mother but we kids felt it as well. Now.
Mamma had to turn around. Oh by the way in the government.
I had introduced what was known as the we don't pay attention
and that was far more substantial A mother didn't have to work any more.
But the house had fruit trees and then we could help ourselves to ankle chalice fruit and vegetables
and you know it was true. There were all the yams where you wanted the pineapples and everything which.
Well I mean we could live out of it. So. It wasn't a financial blow.
And certainly it gave us the chance to go to school which was of course a better school.
You know why the other school at to Malcolm. But it was good for us to be in a bigger.
And we would tune from school in this new house. Now when I am Kate. Mather took a very different role.
She didn't have to go to work as I say. And she became very much more of a mother and housekeeper.
And she had a little sewing room in the new house that she'd like to so she then began to cook just as John had cooked
which amazed us all and we need to say I was cooking you know. But the girl didn't help that much.
None of them helped awfully much they wanted to offer a supporter for mamma.
Not all those two step sisters who were very supportive. But you know we bought Cortef with the kids around the place.
And mother was just there. So we should cook the same evening meal.
And she would mail for Uncle Charlie and walk across the paddock to his place
and put down hot enough for him seven nights a week because ninety cases.
And then she'd come back and get a round table to have AM and now. This house.
We were paying I think mother paid six shillings a week in rain.
And the landlord would come and collect her in once a fortnight. He was a very big deal and.
That he'd lived in a hotel a bachelor who lived in a. And he would come out his horse for the rain.
And he'd call out to you. They Mrs mussing and mother used to go out and you know.
She'd hand him up the reins while he sat on the horse needs right a receipt out and hand it to her
and made sure that he returned a little bit so we stayed. Perhaps and Kate had been about four.
And Uncle Charlie said look I think or you can be a mother or your girls better come and live in the house.
So he built himself a kind of lean to which was.
He was going to live in and he just moved his belongings out and we moved into Katie's house. Now. And we truly did.
Remove the lavatory. And it almost seemed to me as it was a half a mile away from the house.
It wasn't really but I would think it would have been. Hundred meters or much more.
And it was down a little hill as it were from. On one side or lemon trees and on the other side bar and tree.
And you walked down this avenue of tree. To get to it and they are this level tree and it was.
A real reading room and sometimes you know
when someone would go there someone else stand at the top of that you have haven't you.
And roll an orange down to hit their feet. Then the worst of what we call not alone.
The wash house and that was another lane.
So there when you went to the lavatory you had to take your clothes off and put a Galatea
or sort of overall it was similar to theater garments where you just put your arms in and tied at the back
and say You wore that down to the lever tree. And you came back and you took it out of your hand up and.
And there was a cabal except lifeforce a big scrubbing brush and you had to have a scrub.
And they did get dressed again. So this would all of a to.
Well I have very tender memories of being at that house because in many ways. Uncle Charlie became a father.
And he was very highly regarded people knew. And particularly the farmers to him. And he saved a lot of money too.
He had a fair bit socked away. He and Kate had never married. His They did actually. You mean legally.
Also I thought they were brother and sister.
Well that's what I forgot I should have explained this when I first got together they told if you
and I were preferences.
Where it was found that they weren't and I made people believe that but later when they were built a house
and lived together and I said we're not. So which one was related to your Uncle Charlie was a genuine brother.
Yes And Kate only came from the same man and but she really wasn't a sister. So.
I mean it was a man and wife arrangement really it was once a house was built and I settled in. Anyhow. Uncle Charlie.
Of course one.
We lived he had healings which for five years that he put on to fruit
and vegetable from people by the name of B R I was I.
They were very early settlers on the trade among some of the first and it was the second generation.
That was there when we were there and there were three Miss Bray and the elderly mother lived.
None of them had married and they had a marvelous old house made up see these days you just build one house
and you live in it. But those days in the country that offer.
Built two three different houses little smaller ones that made up a into a big house.
And they had a cluster of small houses and I think it keeps the peace in the family because if you get angry.
Lock yourself up away from the rest.
Well that's where the brace lived and I own the land which he paid six pounds a year or less. For police.
And they came by so often just to visit these three unmarried women.
And he used to look after their place and keep it tidy do all kinds of form. And. When I when I would come home.
And homemade biscuits. It was like Santa Claus. Well. Charlie took charge of us. And we honored him.
We respected really honored him. And. He had an eye for value.
So when it was time to make a fresh lot of new dresses he'd take us into town not Martha take the four of us into town.
And there was a drapery shop they about the name of Proudfoot.
And they knew our Proudfoot knew him and his prayer for him and
when he'd go in they'd pull up one of those high chairs and all us kids would gather.
And he'd say don't now you tell Mrs proud for what you are.
And would also like the color of the cloth we'd want for a trace. And he would take afraid.
Out of it just thread and break it to see how strong it was. To see had Europe all and he not. Something most strong.
And she'd bring something else and the real thing. Stays first and future.
Of course absolutely beautiful and more often than not. He'd settle on something like that and for the winter.
He'd settle on surge. You know creeps in the Navy. So. Well you know it forces that for he he came after.
And he said at the head of the table.
And he continued telling the stories we're almost as it were where my father left off
and he had to leave too with an i Phone five price because my auntie Kate wouldn't have him in the kitchen. You see.
And it was as though we were having experienced we were having that experience again.
Sitting around the fire listening to the stories and just as my father would get up to end it all he'd make the coke.
Charlie would do the same thing he'd just get up and reach the big black kettle Mexico and head.
And that meant we had to go to bed. So there was a lot of security there with my Uncle Charlie.
I realize that more today believe it or not. He filled that gap in a very positive.
Though the nature of each other this. Anyhow.
Kind of course you see I went to school I went with went to more than bar I just took it in my stride
but can take are still in kindergarten for a while. And I had had a teacher.
And I used to think if I could play like play the piano and had.
Mors Miss Fairfax and she also would let us dance but it wasn't the same as Miss Gracie not at all.
So there was Jessie. Cat and myself going to school together. So there was that companionship. Did you like school.
I can't say that I did particularly I liked it as I grew older I thought it was more interesting.
And what I was better able to read grown up spokes I found I liked it better.
I have to confess that I had some wonderful school teachers just marvelous school teachers who really took care of me.
You know being the only black kid in a class. It was a pretty lonely life.
And very often I have my sandwich or whatever I had for lunch with the teacher.
And I recall that when I was in the last year in primary. We had a beautiful headmaster they were in.
And sometimes he did me go into his office and had my sandwich well.
And when I finished primary school school was a real challenge. And having to wear a uniform without any choice.
So the last day at primary school I went into the principal's office.
And I had saved my lunch money every Monday we got lunch money
and one day one Monday I went with their lunch so I could to mandates so I could hang on to the. And I bought him.
This was in the depths of the Depression. And I bought him. For a price and.
I went back and I remember knocking on his door and he called out coming in. And I went in.
And I handed him shyly I handed him this. And I looked in his eyes and full of tears. I've never forget that.
So he told me sit down and I just sat there and I found it just to leave him such a beautiful person.
So I went after SCO. And it was so eventful. I couldn't take an interest.
I was not to stay at school but I stayed until I was just on sixty. And I couldn't get away quickly.
Because there were other things opening up if I wanted to read not all I wanted to if it is there was a school library.
Why should I have to depend on the school library. And I had ambitions. And I wanted to.
And I don't look at the primary school of domestic science and I can say that I found it boring I found it intriguing.
You know to learn how to grill or chop properly.
My scarves and all those things and that was rather looked down upon at the time but I can tell you it's stuck with me.
It didn't. Tell me about the School of Library. School of Arts had there.
I had a hall and in the hall was a good stage.
I was very accustomed to that stage in fact because while still in the primary school I was in the choir.
And we did a lot of Shakespeare.
And we would go down and we were allowed to use the hall and put on a Shakespearean play.
And the local mothers would go and watch it.
So I had had I do I was familiar with the stage and we were told how to walk onto a stage and. Do things properly.
And then there was also a competition for singing a state for the local the state fund
and it was always a public school Catholic school
and they would always leave us for dead because the nuns would put their all into it
and we had nobody except this lovely principal who would take us through.
Music lessons but I loved school because of what it offered me in the way music but as far as the school was concerned.
Any book I wanted was there and I would get through two or three books in a week without any trouble.
And they don't begin to think. After writing novels. I'd like to write. Real wishy washy love novels.
You know about people falling in love. Going off to bed together and getting into flash cars and driving around and.
Wearing beautiful clothes and going out to nightclubs
and I had these dreams that one day I would be writing about people like that. Wow.
It didn't quite turn out that way but I had many day dream. And I craved marrying a rich man.
And that he bought me a nice big car. And these were almost you know. That the house meant a lot.
It was nice to go home from school and in the evening once again with my uncle Charlie mother and the other kids.
There it gave me a great feeling of security. I know. There that house and that garden.
And my mother and culture gave me tremendous security. I felt I could go out and face the world. Anywhere at any time.